In China,
there are basically two major issues.
The first issue is that there is not a
lot of intellectual property enforcement
on the streets or in the web rooms on,
so there's a that you can find pirated
material all over China and there's not
been a very effective way of enforcing
that.
We're working on that,
but it's very,
very slow.
The second problem is market access.
The Chinese were severely restrict the
amount of foreign product,
including American product,
a film product that comes into China
illegally,
and I'm not only is that bad in and of
itself,
but then encourages more pirated
material to to be on the streets because
you can find almost anything that has
ever been produced in the history of the
human race in China that's on the
streets illegally.